نكمل اخبار الساعه مشاهدينا من اوكرانيا
تحديدا من الشرق فعقب اشهر من النكسات في
ساحات لاعنف واشرس المعارك بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه روسيا سيطرت على
المدينه وبعد اعلان سقوطها اعلن الرئيس
الاوكراني المدينه الاستراتيجيه قد تكون
خرجت فعلا عن سيطره قواته قبل ان يتراجع
لاحقا حيث قال ان المدينه ليست محتله ومع
ذلك فالمعركه الاطول والتي وصفت بمفرمه
اللحم تكبد فيها طرفان خسائر فاتحه ولا
سيما على الصعيد البشري لكن السؤال هل
تستحق المدينه كل هذا العناء بعض
التقديرات الغربيه والاستخباراتيه اشارت
الى مقتل ما بين 20 الى 30 الف روسيا في
المدينه في حين تتحفظ موسكو عن ذكر
خسائرها في ساحه المعركه تضاف الى تلك
الارقام الكلفه العسكريه ولا سيما وان
قائد افادنير يافيغيني بريكوتين نشاد
مرارا خلال الاشهر الماضيه القاده
العسكريين الروس
لمده بالدعم العسكري
اليوم يقومون بمهمه بالغه الاهميه وهم في
بخموت حتى اليوم ولكن لن اخبرك في اي موقع
بالضبط لكن هذا يعني ان بخموت لم يتم
احتلالها من قبل الاتحاد الروسي لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات